[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
May 16th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
consumers who use buy now pay later
programs like klarna and affirm are
facing a harsh reality being rejected
when it's time to check out wsj personal
finance reporter Amani mois is here to
explain why these programs are
implementing these changes so Amani
first of all what are buy now pay later
programs and why have they become so
popular by now pay later programs are
basically installment lending it's a
form of short-term loan that's available
to Shoppers at the point of sale and
they became really really popular in
recent years because they give people
the option to pay installments usually
for zero interest the most popular
version of this is a pay in for which
means that you get to split your
purchase into four payments two weeks
apart how do these programs compare to
say a credit card or a layaway plan and
who are they geared toward so it's
similar to a credit card in that when
you make the purchase that item is yours
you could take it home but it's
different from a credit card because
they usually don't charge interest and
the pay earn installments as opposed to
a purchase hitting your statement and
you have to pay it off by the end of the
month or you risk paying interest and
it's similar to Layaway in the
installment payments but in a
traditional layaway plan you don't get
to take that item home until you've made
all of your payments they're really
geared towards anyone who shops online
but the demographic of people who are
most comfortable shopping online tends
to be younger consumers however people
who don't have access to more
traditional kinds of credit like credit
cards or other types of loans May Lean
On by now pay later more because it's
seen as more accessible the credit
checks are lighter and because the
payment period is so short they're more
willing to lend to people without a
credit history we've talked on the show
before about how these programs have
made it relatively easy for consumers to
sign up for these payment plans and to
make purchases what's changed for
consumers so more regular buy now pay
later users are finding that they're
being rejected and that's not something
that they're used to and some customers
are finding that their spending limits
have been lowered why are buy now pay
later programs implementing these
changes because buy now pay later
lending is a very rape sensitive
business and because interest rates have
been rising it's become much harder to
offer those zero interest loans so then
by now pay later providers have had to
pull back a lot more than traditional
lenders because while Banks can rely on
deposits to fund loans buy now pay later
companies have to borrow from either
investors or from other Banks to make
their loans that they offer to Consumers
if you find yourself rejected for a buy
now pay later loan when you've maybe
gotten one or just a few weeks earlier
you may wonder what you're doing wrong
but it's possible that recent rejections
may be more due to problems in the
barnal pay later business model than the
applicant's credit you spoke to several
consumers who use buy now pay later and
who run into these changes what do they
tell you well some people really see it
as a wake-up call right A lot of times
when people are relying on buy now pay
later you're probably buying something
that you don't really need maybe if you
could only afford it with forced
installments maybe you just can't afford
it so some people take it as all right I
need to take a breath and maybe not be
as impulsive in my spend ending or
aspirational with my purchases but there
are some people who are feeling
frustrated by this because by now pay
later for some people has become a way
of life one stat that really jumped out
to me was that between 2019 and 2021 by
now pay later loans jumped from two
billion dollars to 24 billion dollars so
a lot of people got used to using these
payment plans pretty frequently now as
you alluded to the buy now pay later
business model seem to benefit from
extremely low interest rates that we saw
over the past several years well now
that interest rates are much higher how
could that change this industry and
consumers experiences going forward it's
getting more expensive to borrow that's
the point of higher interest rates so
it's just going to be much harder to
find zero interest the way that a lot of
Shoppers got accustomed to over the past
few years for example more than
two-thirds of the loans that a firm made
in the most recent quarter had interest
which means that it's not the paying for
plans that so many people got used to
that's Wall Street Journal personal
Finance reporter Amani movies and that's
your money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for
the Wall Street Journal
[Music]